Lucy
[Musique]
gre vas-tu chanter pour te sortir de
cette situation
lu c'est quoi cette tenue on dirait un
clone
lucigr j'en savais rien je te jure
j'étais pas au courant je suis
désolé
[Rires]
comme c'est alléchant de voir vos jeunes
visage rayonnant en ce jour
propice je suis la docteur volume niagul
votre humble haute juge et directrice du
Département des armes expérimentales du
capital je me suis libéré de mon
laboratoire aujourd'hui pour vous
examiner vous les leaders la future
génération je ne serai pas toujours là
après
tout et à cette fin j'ai l'honneur de
vous présenter le créateur des Hunger
Games en
personne le doyen
cas
cherite de la
faculté et bien sûr cher docteur
je vous ai fait venir ici aujourd'hui
pour la 10e cérémonie annuelle de la
moisson cérémonie durant laquelle nous
choisissons deux enfants de chaque
district pour une lutte à mort dans les
arènes du Capitol Lord her Games
elle n'a aucune chance tu l'as vu elle
est sousalimenté
elle est instable le doyen dit qu'il ne
s'agit pas juste de gagner tout est
tjours basé sur la victoire si ce ne
sont pas les jeux c'est vis-à-vis de la
foule Lucy Gry ne survivra pas une
minute une fois dans l'arène ça veut
dire qu'il faut gagner l'amour du public
avant qu'elle y pénètre il faut que je
la fasse rechanter je ne chanterai pas
une seule note pour toi si j'étais à sa
place je ne ferai rien pour toi sauf si
j'avais confiance elle vient des
districts Tigris elle sait qu'on la
déteste et elle veut notre mort comment
veux-tu que je lui donne confiance en
moi imagine que ton nom a été tiré à la
moisson et tu te retrouves à 10
kilomètres de chez toi j'aurais juste
envie qu'une personne se soucie un peu
de moi déjà ne la néglige pas parce
qu'elle vient des districts Corot vous
avait plus de choses en commun que tu ne
le
[Musique]
penses